clock but is he going to bring his rook
back and challenge the blackrook okay
yeah he is that's a nice tactic it's
going to get really complicated but yeah
uh yeah okay there we go this rook
offers itself up but it's purely to
distract black's rook away from
defending the white a pawn promoting so
if the white rook is captured white will
make a new queen you know but he was
only just in time magnus by one move
yeah five seconds
okay five seconds and he takes the white
rook white makes a new queen
and it's queen versus rook black's pawns
are all
uh a bit loose as well this you know
there's two pawns on priest the pawn uh
on the f6 square and the far advanced
pawn and now
well all he has to do is just
move his king to attack the rook and
he's done that 12 seconds no more checks
for black black has to put his rook on a
passive square the black pawn drops and
now it's just a matter of time the white
queen is going to overpower the black
rook i suppose i mean i suppose his only
hope is to get something like queen
versus brook nothing else on the board
which is still winning for white but
it's it's a bit tricky to win yeah i
think he's just going through the
motions the most painful thing just to
resign
um and magnus is all the time in the
world actually magnus can sit here and
wait for five minutes and let him suffer
are the players allowed to go and have a
walk maybe he could go now
chill out a little bit go and get some
sushi
his legs are there yeah he's about to go
that's it that's it it's over magnus
carlson takes the lead